hello everyone welcome to this new video
by simply learn in this video we will
discuss copywriting and the top 10
copywriting tips for beginners any
encouraging text that you see on the
internet whether it is a Facebook ad for
a cosmetic or an Instagram post for
sneakers that makes you to purchase it
is said to be a copy person who writes a
copy is called a copywriter salaries of
copywriters in India may go as high as
5.5 lakhs per year and in U.S it may go
as high as 1.60 000 per year companies
like Deloitte Target Airtel puma and
PepsiCo are hiring copywriters with
handsome salaries so are you excited to
know more about copywriting do you want
to be one if yes then have a look at a
professional certificate program in
digital marketing which covers all the
needs under digital marketing domain
like search engine optimization content
creation which involves copywriting paid
campaigns and much more to know more
find the link in the description box
below
see what our users say about us check
the simply learned success stories find
the link in the description box below so
here is a question for you a copywriter
can work in which of the following
fields
option a marketing option b advertising
option C public relations option D all
of the above do share your answers in
the comment section below and get a
heart from Simply learn so before we
begin consider subscribing to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss any updates from Simply learn
understanding what copywriting is
copywriting is a process of creating a
textual content for ads brochures and
website Pages this helps to Target the
audience for specific actions like
provoking them to sign up or purchase
for Fruitful copywriting it is essential
to have an in-depth understanding of the
target audience a person who does
copywriting is called a copywriter
copywriters can work with a firm or even
freelance however to be a copywriter it
is necessary to have excellent writing
skills the ability to research and
critical thinking for the relevant
Audience by moving ahead in this video
we are going to discuss top 10
copywriting tips for beginners
tip number one understand the target
audience
understanding your target audience is
necessary for successful copywriting
research your target needs and design
your text or copy accordingly use
language that requests your target
audience and addresses the specific
needs this will make your copy more
relatable and effective in grabbing
their attention and ultimately letting
them to take action so suppose if you
are targeting children studying in
kindergarten who finds difficulty to
learn from books then you should focus
on creating a copy that shows how your
product benefits such children the next
is to create strong catchy headline your
headline is the first thing people will
see and it will be the reflection of the
rest of your copy headline should not
only be the attention grabber but also
informative showing exact details of
what your copy is about in a summarized
manner tools like headline analyzer from
co-schedule and monster Insight
copywriters in this task with a good
headline it is important to have a clear
and crisp copy so suppose your product
is animated poems then you can write a
headline and copy as
the next we have is
to be a clear and concise and copy keep
your copy simple and straightforward
avoid using overly technical language or
industry jargon that your target
audience may not understand
our major goal is to communicate the
message that leaves a long impact on the
audience so try using short sentences
bullet points and subheadings to make
your copy easy to understand
tools like copy dot Ai grammarly and
word tune can help you in this task
find the given example for your
reference
next tip is more towards the voice and
how your sentences should sound like
should use active voice while forming
the sentences
writing an active voice makes your copy
more engaging and easier to understand
it puts the focus on the subject and
highlights their actions making your
copy more relatable in contrast writing
in passive voice can make your copy feel
distant and disinterested skinlet and
sapling are the tools that can help
copywriters to transform passive voice
content into active voice now compare
the above example with its passive
version
moving towards the next step always
focus on benefits people are more
interested in the benefits that your
product or Services can provide to them
rather than knowing the list of features
when writing your copy focus on the
outcomes and results that your product
or service will deliver
this will help to connect with your
target audience on an emotional level
and convince them to take action
consider the given example how to write
a grade copy by focusing on benefits
the next tip is to incorporate
storytelling stories are the best way to
connect with people incorporating a
story into your copy can help you to
engage your target audience and make
your message more memorable your story
should focus on the problems that your
audience are facing and then the
solution how your product or Services
solves this problem few storytelling
tools that may prove helpful to
copywriters includes with me and
storyboard that
find the given example to understand how
you can frame your copy in the form of a
story
the next step we have is a must-have
call to action your copy should always
have a clear call to action
asking the audience to do what you
expect next this could be anything from
purchasing a product signing up or
contacting your company for the details
an ideal call to action should be
specific and easy to follow copy dot AI
can help you to add more effective ctas
in your copy here is a small example
showing how you can add a CTA
next is to include some compelling
phrases the language you use in your
copy can greatly impact its
Effectiveness choose phrases that
encourages the reader to take actions
say for example
you can have this now limited time offer
and don't miss out
click now and get discount of X percent
can be powerful motivators you can also
use the tools like word tune and quill
board to write compelling phrases you
can have a look at the example here
with this make sure that your copy go
through a grammar check so before
submitting do a proof reading put
grammar and spelling errors can harm
your repetition make sure to check for
typos incorrect word usage and sentence
structure you may ask your colleagues or
mentor to review your copy in case of
second thoughts you can also take the
help of some online tools like grammarly
the last and the final tip test your
copy EB testing can help to determine
what works best for your target audience
allowing you to make improvements and
optimize your copy for maximum
effectiveness
continuously testing and refining your
copy is an important part of copywriting
process and will help you to achieve
better results over time you can take
the help of EB testing tools like vwo
and Google optimize
copywriting is a crucial aspect of
marketing and requires deep
understanding of target audience clear
and concise language and a persuasive
approach by following these top 10
copywriting tips for beginners you can
improve your skills and create a copy
that effectively captures your target
audience's attention and persuads them
to take action remember always to keep
your target audience in mind use active
voice emphasize benefits incorporate
storytelling include a clear call to
action use persuasive language proof
radio copy and continuously test and
refine your approach with practice and
determination you can become a
successful copywriter and achieve your
marketing goals here is a gender
reminder for you if you want to become a
skilled copywriter and digital marketing
professional then have a look at a
professional certificate program in
digital marketing by simply learn get
the course Link in the description box
below to get latest updates from Simply
learn do subscribe to our Channel and
hit the Bell icon
to never miss any updates so keep
watching and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you